hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is our you garbage I am your host H
Foley coming at you from beautiful
Astoria Queens my co-host is coming at
you from an undisclosed location
somewhere in southern New Jersey we're
not sure we're down in the bunker baby
very tight lid on it ladies and
gentlemen Kevin Kippy James Ryan Kippy
tell these bozos what they need to know
like how you're doing like 90s game
shows for this relax guys just thanks
for tuning in make sure you rate review
subscribe on iTunes full video is
available on YouTube you can subscribe
there as well
we appreciate it thank you yes sir and
let me take it back to H folio folks
it's 503 traffic little jammed up on the
Van Wyck gang I'm gonna tell you right
now New York City all right we're in
peak week here that's what they're
calling it during this coronavirus and
we went out and got one of the best we
could possibly get we're treating it
like sweeps week all right because we
got a rockstar in the building today
ladies and gentlemen I don't know what
to say one of the funniest people I know
absolutely brilliant stand-up comedian
you seen her on guy code you seen her on
girl code and this I just saw hot ones
she's got a hot ones Oh kids an icon
we're talking legit famous here you got
Gaga and you got the kid right here
ladies and gentlemen so happy to have
her here she's also the host of amazing
podcast secret-keeper relation gentleman
Carly Aquilino everybody very good when
we do shows together I always I I love
it I love it I always want I always want
people to feel good and there's never a
time that I don't mean it because that's
the way I and show everybody we don't
have anybody on here that we don't
genuinely love and like you know
generally respect and even when and when
I'm hosting you can always tell who I'm
phoning in for tonight yeah he's okay
I've been I don't know but like he's he
he least he gives great he's forgotten
my name recently like I've been best
friends with them for nine years we've
been working together
Calvin Brian everybody Kelvin Brian he
made eye contact with me and just
completely blanked on my name like
within the calendar year easy of two
first names he could have put him in any
order you know anybody could have just
went like ryankevin anything he just got
everybody gets the red carpet but me
Kevin Kevin everybody Kevin Kevin I
think that stuff's fun though I love I
love when like [ __ ] up [ __ ] happens as
you just knock something over
yeah I think we bought it at like
Central Parker center yes looks very
luxurious thank you it's all it's all my
lady she works in interior design I
would be sleeping in a sleeping bag at a
pizza place it wasn't there she does she
does everything just ordered a couple
new lamps off the old what is it West
Elm or whatever it's called yeah maybe
wait there I'm thinking a Wayfarer
[Laughter]
Wayfarer is for sure trash do you ever
see there's like there's like Instagram
accounts or like you know blogs or
whatever dedicated to like reality like
Wayfarer vers reality like they send the
couch and the couch ends up only being
like 25 inches long now I think they I
think they do have some stuff that is
you know nicer but the most the most of
its like you're like oh it counts for
120 bucks this is gonna be great and
then you get it and it's literally for
like dolls and children what is what is
the level of classy too trashy as far as
those are concerned west on would be the
top now like all of them isn't there's
like big box stores yeah I think would
be West Elm right
Barn is really nice don't sleep on
pottery barn really re barns nice yeah
pottery barn's like luxury and then I'm
trying to think Oh Crate and Barrel I
feel like it's nice seeing bees nice and
be a man yes yes yes yes I'm well aware
oh well I furnished an apartment or two
where does where does that Rena Center
fall into that kinetic Flanagan's
boley's only got two more payments left
on that left on his left on his couch
they're gonna come take the mic from me
and two seconds I'm gonna get a payment
in I remember I remember when Bed Bath &
Beyond was like really classy yeah I'm
from from outside of Philadelphia I was
like yeah I remember when Sears was hot
[ __ ] you had a couple of shirts from
Sears you were closing deals at happy
hour I think they are there's a local
mall and like it's that off the whole
side of that malls jasira suck out the
whole side of the mall it's Sears
JCPenney wait I think pennies is still
kicking pennies in my hometown bill
Kenny's ain't bad you find a couple of
deals on some [ __ ] betting over a
pennies on a Saturday this is like
probably traveling I love being in a
place where I'm like I can buy clothes
[Laughter]
lawn mower was perfect there I gotta
find a weed whacker to go with his jeans
I they were always all that stuff was
always in the on the bottom floor to
remember like below street level you go
down there it was cooler in there like
it felt temperature cooler it was like
the vague scent of fertilizer you walk
down there with your flute your parents
really
the [ __ ] going on it was the purchaser
at Sears that was like listen we got it
well you know yeah I'm sure we sell
underwear but what do you say we get
into the mower business so crazy what a
crazy think about think about that now
if you go if you tell people like yeah
see like try to tell us
somebody was born in like 98 what Sears
was they were like what the [ __ ] get
back to back-to-school stuff and a leaf
blower
ready for the whole fall but I remember
I remember I remember like when like
Woolworths was like was like a thing you
guys are too young remember wait yeah
you're way too young there was one left
they went under they didn't make it out
of the 80s I don't like a shitty target
like it was like imagine if target was
owned by like one guy managed all the
targets like all of them had just weird
thing it was not you said that's so
sweetly you were like was it like a
Macy's is that what it was like a
William in Sonoma that sounds like an
old like a name that's like an America
though JG Woolworths or whatever they
used to have a counter in there I'm
sorry to cut you off they used to have a
counter in there where you can like eat
like a lunch counter that's what we're
talking about if you can get lunch in
the store next to the mowers oh you
could eat while shopping for trousers so
that's like Costco there's always yeah
that's like inception of trashing your
eating in a Pizza Hut inside a target
that's that's like multiple level of
[ __ ] garbage to Russian nesting doll
I love garbage right but I'll tell you
what man you're a little kid you're
walking through those department stores
you grab a [ __ ] super pretzel soft
pretzel and maybe an icy that's [ __ ]
clean
right there that's a tree that's a tree
that would be like if me and my mom were
gonna have like a special day mm-hmm
like Sears walk around that [ __ ] was
awesome you know what I always loved and
I know this is a really garbage thing of
me this is that this is shows how poor I
am but I used to love even as a little
kid when we walk into like
Bloomingdale's or Macy's or one of those
department stores and we'd walk through
the perfume department yeah I always
loved coming through there all the
classy ladies selling perfume and stuff
like Mel's real good they always look
nice I just picture I picture a fat
eight-year-old Foley walking through
like hey look at these classy broads
over here hey Margot you look at Doris
huh the new estate law
ah how do I score what a classy broad
like Elaine over here no that's what I'm
saying yeah they would they were like
they were like you know middle-aged
older ladies they're always like dress
nice they smelled good they didn't take
any [ __ ] either that was like a career
that was like oh she's afraid you know
she's the she's the perfume lady down at
Penny's and that was like a that was a
thing you could just yeah that wasn't
for like people in Community College or
anything good they always dated mobsters
those ladies they're always dating a
bookie or something like that
hmm we do what to get out of the house
or something
mm-hmm yeah I used to love that trash
she's trashy times is the kid and it was
the best thing ever
ladies and gentlemen as you know our
very special guest today is Carly
Aquilino Carly Kevin and I are gonna ask
you a few questions here and we're gonna
find out are you garbage holy what do
you I'm saying know what dude I'm
looking at [ __ ] exposed brick wall
with cool lighting no and she's drinking
kombucha what are you talking about this
is she's a trendsetter literally that's
what I thought
see that yes that's what I thought you
were from Long Island
it's a change you can change it singing
you can get a little bit of cash you can
buy some nice things like you can you
can anybody can buy brick right but that
doesn't that doesn't clear that doesn't
clean slate the here's the here's the
thing and I mean this honestly I'm gonna
kiss your ass a little bit here I mean
this honestly you you have something
that's just cool about you okay so it
doesn't matter even if you do something
trashy it's always gonna be classy like
let me give you an example okay I love
the way you dress I think you dress so
cool okay and I think the last time we
worked together this is what she was
wearing Kippy she had on a pair of cool
jeans but just regular jeans like kind
of like faded jeans a black turtleneck
and a Dale Earnhardt t-shirt yeah that's
good listen if you put that on me you
love a pit crew guy you look like a guy
who changes the tires on Dale
Earnhardt's car if you put that on me
I'm selling oil paintings at a [ __ ]
gas station all right and dude
she looked so [ __ ] cool wearing it so
I'm saying classy and I mean that a
hundred percent I'm saying classy all
the way but I know we're gonna find a
little garbage under their fingernails I
guarantee that Kippy you want to lead
off you I may hit it with some of that
some of the basics I hit her with some
of the basics yeah what's how did you go
up in Long Island okay I've learned
there's two kind of suffix the trash you
want to not trash you on well pretty
much Queens okay some really nice areas
but the rest of its just like whatever
it's just suburban where I'm probably
there was no like oh we gotta go to coal
back to visit we had a target a TJ Maxx
Marshalls don't even get me started
I like Marshalls I love my wife is from
germs she just moved she's from Germany
and there's Marshalls in our
neighborhood and it's like she's she's
there four times a day she's talking to
the people stacking the shelves she's
like when you get you're good to live
they're like Tuesday's comment on
Tuesday it's [ __ ] if he told her it
was Barney's yeah you don't know look
around whatever you want hej max love
the Marshalls I love a good t.j.maxx man
you find some nice stuff in there some
wines oh yeah oh yeah they got the coach
next next to the luggage I love that
what about you know what you know was a
was like was like premium when we were a
kid but I know is garbage now his
Burlington Coat Factory dad a Burlington
at the start of December get a couple of
winter coats ease on us bad news I
always eat the snacks this is what I
don't get how many coats at the end of
the winter did they throw away because
that place was literally it was like
[ __ ] it just it was like where they
keep the Ark of the Covenant you just
went on forever of just [ __ ] coats
yeah they probably kept them yeah yeah I
remember one time I don't know why this
was so I was so out of character from my
mom list of coat factor just reminded me
she took us to a sock Factory one time
she's like we're gonna get a deal legit
legit remember being in the parking lot
I was like seven I go I'm like mom I'm
not going into a [ __ ] sock Factory
there is no way in hell no way I don't
care I mean were we worried poor we had
money like we grew up upper-middle class
and she's like we're going to a sock
Factory I'm like oh we're not if she's
like we'll get a good deal I'm like what
are you talking about good bleep as they
make the shocks there let's go to
Penny's like a [ __ ] gentleman and get
a get a pair of Hanes on China where the
[ __ ] get them fresh that way so hot when
they come and oppress my mom
like them keep your feet warm put him
right on mate this week there's no way
they made the socks there this foot
collie this [ __ ] guy walks around
acting like he's a [ __ ] Kennedy to me
all right because of the county he grew
up in Pennsylvania but I don't know if
it was close I've never seen it again it
wasn't like I drove by it on the way to
school I think I refused to go in I
think every met I think I legit refused
to go in and I think my mom later went
in but I was like keep me in the station
wagon lady no [ __ ] chance
she was probably working there didn't
want to tell you it was gonna ask her
about that I'm gonna add that you saying
me realizing Burlington Coat Factory
coach Factory we're just jog that memory
I gotta talk to her about that's too
funny folks do you like fresh socks
right off the press sure we all do come
on the Lenny sock Factory well keep him
warm for you what was the Carly what was
the name of the grocery store you went
to growing up that's a big one
I've never been what the connection
we're all bound I've heard of it only
from New Yorkers no King Cullen's class
II I've seen a couple of those out there
on the island not too shabby
it's kind of like a key okay that's when
we found out key foods are India but
that's what we found out through this
game key phones are individually owned
so you got you can go to a key foods
it'll be a [ __ ] hole in the wall dump
or you go to a nice one
then I went to one that was like the the
floor was like they didn't block it off
but it was a hundred percent like under
construction step in a wet concrete well
you know the biggest shock to me was
when I got to this coming into the city
and you guys being from the burbs you
get it to is that every grocery store in
New York City always has like four or
five cats that patrol the place right
and what the scent of cat litter when
you walk into a groceries my grocery
store on the corner that's the first
thing that hits you when you walk in
yeah why bodega cats are different I
like the bodega cat yeah I liked I like
to I like to catch the grocery store too
but when you're walking in a you know
you know a wave of fresh step slapped in
your face there is nothing better I'm in
the suburbs right now there's honestly
from being in the city for so long
there's nothing better than a suburban
grocery store the aisles are big they're
clean there's only like 10 people in the
whole store it's so refreshing yeah I
recently went to my demons Oh Wakemans
is [ __ ] a plus yeah it's so good
there's a couple of those in it like
where I'm from and it's like that would
be like a field trip we're like we're
going to leg men's I'm like I'm in let's
go oh there are Christmas [ __ ] exposed
brick the cool lights added the cool
tattoos anything trashy
if you get access to a vehicle and you
go you can go anywhere on the eastern
seaboard what do you want to do babe
take me to legmen that's funny that
reminds me of our buddy Brendan's tag
right love him to death somebody won
that at the club was asking him if he if
all of a sudden tomorrow you got a
hundred million dollars what's the first
thing you would do you know Brendan's
answer was go to Disneyland I loved him
that that that's the equivalent of when
he got a car what do you want to go I
want to go to Whiteman's yeah he's yeah
he's he's Long Island he's not even he's
not even close to getting out of it he
has leaned into it and he is really
[ __ ] embraced on the trash he's the
best man it's so funny we went to we
just we were doing shows outside of the
city had levity live a couple of right
before this all happened we were there
and I drove them back but I've every
night every night we would get to the
toll and he wouldn't he'd be like oh
that's an expensive toll and like
wouldn't even reach for dangerous money
or anything like 16 bucks for the toll
Jesus Christ that's a lot and I'm
sitting there like yeah I know jerk-off
what the [ __ ] you did the feature he was
hosting all right I got one did you have
a fake Christmas tree growing up a lot
of Italian a lot of Italians have fake
Christmas trees for some reason you you
answered that like we were asking you a
better murder you were like well listen
it's a long it's not what you think fake
one in like a different like a different
living room or something class
that's classy that is I gotta give you
that like dining room and then one in
the TV room yeah which ones you to put
the presents under the real one of the
fake ones okay what was like for display
but they had it up every year that pass
you pass that's all right okay okay two
quarters trees is [ __ ] classy no
that's a good look I got to do that
follow-up question of that
do you remember what the latest date was
that the Christmas tree and the
Christmas decorations would come down
usually my mom would do it the first
week of January after the new year good
no checks out pretty classy it's pretty
clean one final question on the
Christmas tree
were there any colored lights on your
Christmas tree yes you go all white no
they're tract compared to classic white
lights as classy classy do you guys
remember the ceramic lamps they work
they look like Christmas trees and they
had the color little things on them
that's nice garbage but they're [ __ ]
awesome yeah my mom still puts it out to
this day it's nice its own like yes so
sits on the windowsill she makes like oh
she makes like a window display with
like a band it's the same stuffing from
since literally 1982 she's been like
that for like fake snow I'm like we
haven't had company in six years what
are you doing lady get a glove get in
the game will you when I was a kid my
dad used to put trains up like Lionel
trains we put them up around the
Christmas tree that was always weird to
me I'm sorry trains and crisp get out of
here it's presents it's rain great but
one year we didn't have any fake snow so
we used the we used artificial mashed
potatoes nah wait what smashed potatoes
from where artificial the pot of the
flakes that are in like a box oh my god
the dog got into it it was a hole you
decorated your house with depression
food oh my god
Foley that's sadder than the [ __ ]
sock Factory oppression Putin had eggs
in the tree buddy you got
[ __ ] government cheese on the
windowsills what are you doing
powdered eggs roasting at your door
gingerbread house ever
it's just crackers you know you know
what else is trashy on Christmas this
turns into a Christmas edition I love it
my dad my dad did he would go get a
[ __ ] third cuz my parents got
divorced so my mom kept kept ran a tight
ship around Christmas she didn't a very
traditional whatever my dad he would buy
like a 19-foot tree and then we'd
literally have to cut it in half so it
wasn't didn't even have a point
we cut the whole top off why that's it
from the bottom you idiot I have no with
you every year every year we had a flat
top tree he look like he was in [ __ ]
Run DMC us he had the [ __ ] the Box
got a Christmas boys get beat with the
presents under the Christmas pudding
shot up I know he was trying he was I
gotta give him that but he would also do
tinsel on the tree which is what you
you'd be picking up off the ground
through August [ __ ] God everywhere that
we never got that I never even as a
little kid I was like what the [ __ ] is
this it would always shock my fingers
every time like [ __ ] bigs bitin me
you go out you buy a tree you spend
hours decorating it letting it fall
whatever and then you throw that [ __ ] I
never got it it ruins it I don't like it
either I have a question about something
trashy that has to do with Christmas
kind of lay it on us canned cranberry
sauce trashy dude I cannot believe we've
talked about this has come up listen yes
is it trashy like a week ago like a week
ago I had some a week ago is it trashy
to us to people like us no it's not okay
I mean if you go to the you know you're
not going to the rockefellers and eat
for Thanksgiving and you're not gonna
get canned cranberry sauce you know I
always liked it
good but then I'm like literally it's in
the shape of a can the lines are in it
you can you can see the expiration date
on it you're like what is this oh yeah
yeah yeah I don't know but it is I don't
know we say water is it questionable
like Thanksgiving Christmas being like
is this nice or is this not you got to
chop it up and you got to mix it up a
little bit it is garbage but it is
[ __ ] delicious I had some literally a
week ago with chicken cutlets I can't
believe I don't even [ __ ] with it on the
on the holidays I don't know I had a
water out of a dark web
Foley's got a canned cranberry connect
he's got a plug I gotta go through four
chain to get my hands
it's a passable it is garbage but it's
acceptable it's a passable passable
offense yeah additional garbage why
we're on food I got a couple yeah let's
keep moving through the house I like
this this is fun for food when was the
last time you had Bagel Bites like three
four years and I'm only saying that
because I don't know how long how long
that's good that's acceptable very
acceptable but at another they're good I
got another what was the last time you
had a hot pocket oh I had a hot pocket
like six months ago
what kind was it it was okay not my
fault I was on the road and I was
staying in a lake you know how they have
like Holiday Inn Express is they have
like the corner of the hotel that like
has snacks and one thing stinks pants it
stinks but it's like most of the time
when you come home late after a show and
you're on the road you're like what am I
gonna [ __ ] do it's either this or
7-eleven so whatever so the only hot
thing they have is a hot pocket which I
always like the pepperoni pizza clip
you're gonna slum it salami with a
pepperoni
they're so good but this one was ham and
cheese which it
doesn't float my boat but I did enjoy it
yeah it's respectable when Hot Pockets
tried to do the light versions like the
lene lene pockets get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ] I'm not buying
the frozen you know burrito essentially
free yeah exactly of course how do you
feel about frozen foods in general you
can you do a Lean Cuisine or a hungry
man or I really don't I don't eat them
that much but I I don't mind frozen food
and I don't mind like dried like ramen
and stuff like that I still eat that
stuff yeah me too I love it it's garbage
but I love it you uh you had mentioned
settle and I I do forget to a lot of
times on the road we are you know when
comics go on the road we're obviously
forced to only we can only eat what's
afforded available at certain times but
you say in 7-eleven reminded me have you
ever had a taquito and or a chicken
roller from 7-eleven yes taquitos aren't
too shabby I mean they'll hit this spot
I know pretty good pretty good they are
and you know I I'm not gonna lie to you
guys there's no shame in that you're
among friends here come on shameful than
a taquito I well I think I did see I
think that I think the thing with hot
dogs from anywhere quickly like that
it's pretty shameful what's like if
you're eating but they're delicious
that's good I don't know what they do to
that roller man that slow cooking baby
nothing kicks off this summer like a
[ __ ] Slurpee and a big bite dude in
high school one time I went to her my
buddy's house like a 4th of July party
or whatever and his parents we were they
rolled out a hot they had they own a hot
dog roller for like we
like a big fourth of July birthday or
party or whatever so you're there all
day eating drinking you just walk up to
that hotdog brother
they're just hundreds of them spending
all day long I didn't even know you I
didn't even know like a household
goodbye one of those things I don't know
if they still do this now but on that
same tip a big thing at parties for us
when I was a kid is when because
everybody always got kegs of beer kegs
of beer was like what was always at a
party when I was a little kid but for
the kids they would sometimes get a keg
or root beer is that something that you
guys did and as a kid yes like a seven
year old was the coolest [ __ ] thing
if you rolled up to a party like a
graduation party for like your cousin's
friend or and you roll up and they're
like there's a keg of group beer over
there you're this oh my god that's that
and a hot dog roller good night you
start handing out Solo cups taking money
from the kids let's go a kid and you
would go out to like I don't know
Applebee's or something with your
parents one of those restaurants and you
would order a root beer and how [ __ ]
cool it felt to drink it out of their
beer bottle yeah would think oh this
six-year-old is hammered it made me feel
cool I did the same thing I would do
like maybe if I hide the label they'll
think I'm drinking a beer like look like
like the table next to me was just gonna
buy that family's letting the
six-year-old drink of beer you know
you're hitting on the waitress
how long you worked there pops my boys
oh that's too funny what was the what
was the the orange juice situation
growing up what did you what did you
guys do was it Tropicana was it Sunny
Delight wasn't Tang was it five alive
where we at my mom never ever bought
Sunny Delight or any anything like that
she wouldn't let us
but I wanted it so bad but she wouldn't
let us have it but she would buy
Tropicana orange juice or Tropicana
banana strawberry orange juice I feel
like I'm the only guy that was allowed
to drink something to light when I was
you know how you know you know you know
sunny the lights bad and how trashy it
is you can find it not refrigerated at a
grocery store oh yeah they just have it
out right there's like a box on the
floor yes still yeah doesn't get any
shelf space there's no wires like you
could that's like you know how Twinkies
never expire yeah how the apocalypse
fully by science I mean I'm not a doctor
but I'm sure you've eaten enough
Twinkies and drank enough SunnyD that
you should have enough of those
particles in you that you should be able
to essentially live forever fully your
body should never deteriorate actually
it can stick and send me to Mars with no
spacesuit and those two things
Lunchables what those in high school
because I was too old they didn't have
those when I was a kid I was I was
getting them in high school in college
no yes you pack a lunch or did you buy
lunch at school I my mom would pack me a
lunch but I most of the time didn't like
the lunch if my mom wouldn't make its
first of all so embarrassing the lunch
that she made me she would quickly I
love it fresh what's fresh mozzarella
cheese and roasted red peppers are like
Italian bread and like and like like
macaroni salad I'm like mom I'm [ __ ]
11 you
that was like you were like a weird
foreign exchange student yes if you put
a little shot as a bouquet in there for
after an espresso couple biscottis at
the lunch table I was making him change
seats you were sitting next to me with
the kitchen you're back in the kitchen
can you can you heat up my mom's cutlets
please oh my god the only kid at school
with in any pasta course I love it
this is gonna take my my garbage meter
to a whole nother level so my mom worked
in the school in the cafeteria that she
was a lunch lady in my cafeteria in my
school that's awesome
and she worked there for 20 years and
people would like go up to her like
other teachers because I wouldn't want
to sit in the same cafeteria sir there
were two and the teachers that had duty
in my cafeteria they would go to my mom
be like what are you sending her to
school
she's got a hot bar over here she's
setting up [ __ ] chafing dishes
catering yeah got sternos going oh
that's funny veal front stays for lunch
I love it that's a little muscles you
got some muscles in a red sauce going
alright let's stay in the house cuz I
this is so much fun it's going into the
bathroom growing up was it first of all
did you have any carpet in your bathroom
was your bathroom carpeted no very nice
what about like the soaps and stuff like
that what were you guys work on what did
you use bars dial did you have bottles
for the most part it was like a soul
crowd of a soap dispenser like handsome
handsome yeah yeah and then in the
shower I thought that was in the shower
I was gonna be like Jarell on the sink
on mistake our bar soap yeah I don't
think we ever my mom sold Avon so we
sometimes had like Avon products in the
shower no no did she did she sell
skidding so soft was that an Avon
product your bottle with the green yeah
yeah very distinct smell skin so soft we
used to use them to keep bugs away can
ugh they that's what they told us that's
we did the same thing to us that was
like off Skin So Soft was like oh yeah
yeah I could still smell it now if I
think about it's like powder like like
musky powder I love it it takes me right
back to the sock Factory Americana must
be cooking the ankle socks today it
smells delicious I got one that I've
never fully mean you have never
discussed
well the impetus of this game just came
from me and Foley just going through
each other's houses and be like this is
[ __ ] trash well I never talked to you
about did you ever know anybody or in
your family ever have like a cushioned
toilet seat I remember cutting my ass on
those things because the [ __ ] ring
yeah the where the plastic meant was
like a [ __ ] switchblade what was that
all about
I had a friend or someone in my life
when I was young that had a bush like I
remember telling my mom like it's so
comfortable we should get one my mom's
like that's just good so gross-looking
back that's [ __ ] trash man we had a
few of those I remember when a new one
of those came in you're like
it was like room service just came in
dad must have hit the number nice let's
go
nice and fresh we were so trashy - did
you guys have the toilet paper cozy
there was one roll of toilet paper on
top of the toilet that had like a
crocheted thing on top of it on top of
the one back up yeah we left ours under
the sink I want to stay in the bathroom
here I want to hit you with a
multiple-choice question okay okay I
take this from my past experience this
happened at a friend of Mines house all
right so adult life you're staying over
at a friend's house okay get it up in
the morning to brush your teeth all
right when you brush your teeth you
knock their toothbrush on the floor now
it doesn't go in the toilet obviously
but it goes close to the toilet multiple
choice do you a tell the friend
immediately all right and admit admit
what happened be just wash it off with
scalding hot water and put it back and
don't say anything to anybody or see
none of the above just put it back and
keep it moving like it never happened it
was it's close enough and like you know
if the toilet was right next to the sink
it fell near the toilet it could be in
the circle in the peeper and then the
pee perimeter if that's what you're
asking
really yeah that would be like I dropped
your I dropped your toothbrush on the
floor just FYI yeah that's a full this
question seems like it's you've done
this first of all for I did it to you
like five years ago
jzuk so imagine if your friend
that's it I'm safe and this happened at
your house at five years ago I'm sorry
I'm telling ya you told them what are
they gonna yell at you like dollar
ninety-nine yeah exactly
what about just rinsing it off in
scalding hot water and putting it back
that's not I
that if it was just on the floor floor
but not it was near the toilet hmm so
I'm garbage yeah she was right yep you
are yeah yeah yep no way I have one from
from a listener wants to nose from
gutter sloth a fan of the podcast did
you ever own a tire swing was there a
tire swing in your backyard how cool is
that that was Billy's dose yeah I think
people like in the south and you got to
be a pretty reckless parent to have one
of those things cuz I remember them
being like not not like we're it's flat
but with the tires like standing
straight up and it's literally just a
rope yeah I do a tree where you would
sit on it like a motorcycle and swing
back and forth
yeah there's no they weren't tested by
anybody yeah garbage big-time garbage
I had one growing up baby it was [ __ ]
great you run off the school bus like
three or four you just dive onto that
thing for hours so dangerous insanely
dangerous no we I mean my neighbor like
cracked her head open on it like it was
the guy yeah like we got hurt yeah I
went on a friend's trampoline when I was
little I and I cut it one of the springs
went all the way up into my foot and I'm
kicked my leg to think that it would
come out but it sliced my whole foot
Jesus yeah and that was like the first
and only time I was ever on a yeah but
yeah it's crazy looking back that's
insane you see what they do now they dig
holes and then put the trampoline in a
hole so it's flat with the ground level
right so you're not falling off of the
trampoline right that's so scary yeah
oh that's pretty good they also have the
nets now Phil yeah
[ __ ] yeah then that's a weak have
fear a danger was that was the was the
best I was like jumping off roofs you
guys ever jump off roofs when you were a
kid like jump off the garage roof or
something yeah that's also not like
really a girly thing you know not like
girly but like that's usually a lot of
young boys are like let me see if I can
jump off the roof you know he would jump
into a pool or something like that yeah
you jump off like the jump off the roof
of the house and into the pool in the
backyard yeah that's crazy I mean
[ __ ] Evel Knievel what are you
talking about wait for this next one
have you ever uh did you ever have a jet
pack and what are you talking about did
you have a skirt did you have a pool
growing up car you me both came game
over yeah let me ask you a question
settle something for me okay tell me
that the feeling of jumping into an
above-ground pool in the summer isn't
better than jumping into an below ground
pool because it's so much cooler and
refreshing yeah in my backyard and then
jump in usually made of aluminum not
sturdy right well my parents my parents
people I've heard say an above-ground
pool is better than an in-ground pool
are people with the but above-ground
pool yeah I mean yeah to be fair I've
never had yeah it's fantastic no I mean
don't get me wrong
you keep working hard one of these days
you spend money on the exposed brick get
yourself an in-ground pool this is how
trashy my parents are right now we had a
legit above-ground pool when I was
really when I was young that had like
the aluminum deck built onto it and that
thing was like working on the Empire
State Building in the 20s it was [ __ ]
dangerous when they we got one when I
was like just out of high school so what
they did is they buried the pool like
three feet in the ground and then built
a deck around it so now we're rocking
the above-ground in-ground baby
trampoline is what you did so it's like
probably three feet above the ground
awesome you know yeah yeah same thing
yes I'm so glad you had an above-ground
pool he always makes money because of
that you know I don't make I yet they're
trash that's the trash this it's the
second trashiest pool you could have the
other one is like the blow-up one that
you put the one that can be those things
ain't bad in the summer in 30 there it's
not bad I'm sure of course
well if we're ranking pools that's
definitely the last pool right right you
know and then and then above-ground an
inground like a gentleman I like a good
sprinkler sprinklers are our sprinkler
love a sprinkler did you know I had the
the all the wavy the big fly the guys
that had that yeah what do you want Gulf
course what do you my dad had one of
those in the front yard but the one in
the backyard was would run through sure
the other ones so it's like a fire did
you take your cap off yeah good I think
I got one or two more maybe we haven't
even got out of
I never been going for 53 minutes in
here I got one you ready
go for it Carly do you own a cactus or
any cacti Oh
oh boy oh wow that's huge I have so many
plants plants are good cactuses are
garbage this is garbage cactuses are the
best
you think I also do I also don't think
Foley has a reasoning for why they're
garbage this is the second time he's
asked this question and he really
doesn't have an excuse for it he just
goes oh trash the easiest to take care
of I feel like you only get cactus I
feel like you only get cactus is that
like like Renaissance Fairs or like
state fairs or like that is the
stupidest thing that is such
above-ground pool mentality that I I
don't even know what to say to that you
[Music]
know car come on you know the
Renaissance the Renaissance took place
in Arizona everybody knows that there
Amarillo all right here's the here's the
real reason why okay this is like this
is like a boogeyman story for garbage
people
when I was a kid we were always told to
be wary of cactuses because one of my
mom's friends of a friend you know some
lady that cut her hair or whatever would
tell a story about her sister one time
brought a cactus home from somewhere
bought a cactus right at home and she
noticed over a couple of days that the
cactus was like pulsating a little bit
alright and then one day she went to
work and she came home and the
practice had exploded and there was
thousands of baby scorpions everywhere
in the house
I don't old wives tale that happened
that happened to Mike my aunt's friend
to do that it's such an old wives I know
it's like are never in garbage folklore
that's how the old Irish Catholic women
say to scare you like that's so not even
a thing well that's why I think they're
garbage Wow I mean yes yeah that's scary
that's so I I think that's totally
debunked all right did you have a sweet
16 growing up no no okay good 16 but we
went to Florida on the coaster like
inland um we went to Universal Studios
at the Hard Rock Hotel do you want to
have a sweet 16 or do you want to go
away and I was like I literally have no
purpose so why would I was 16 so then we
went to Florida that's all they're big
out in Long Island right sweet sixteens
our informants foes all of that we love
a party yeah have you guys ever heard of
a Kissimmee st. cloud in Florida do you
guys know what I'm talking about I don't
say I don't even know what those words
were semi Kissimmee st. cloud it's a
it's a destination of Florida that isn't
like Disney World Universal it's missing
me that's yeah Kissimmee
yeah Kissimmee it's not on the coast
it's like it's like a I remember people
saying where people would tell me
they're going there for vacation I was
like what the [ __ ] what are you gonna go
to mainland Florida yeah I've only been
there I've only have ever been to Disney
and Miami that's it okay yeah it's good
all right I got one more
did anybody in your family play
scratch-off lottery tickets no oh no
lottery winners in your family no we
used to get we used to get scratchers we
still do for like in our stocking at
Christmas every birthday card oh yeah
that'll put a couple in there the gas
station by my parents house I remember
there was for my whole life every single
day there was a guy there doing
scratch-off tickets all day every day I
don't know it was like he had like one
in like the 80s or the 90s or something
he won like ten thousand dollars and
keeps him coming back I used to work I
used to work at a supermarket outside of
Philly when I was in high school and
they had implemented they used to have
to come to you to buy them and then they
put the machine in at one point and the
machine they had they had that figured
out too when the machine would be
restocked with the new wheels of tickets
and the people thought that the
beginning tickets on the wheel were the
lucky ones they were the winners but
they found out like the the change the
schedule of deliveries that they would
go up and they would wait in line and
fight with each other
like I want the winners I won I was just
sitting like you're all losers no they
would win like ten bucks five I mean
they'd spend a hundred and win a free
ticket you know yeah yeah every once in
a while we'll get like during Christmas
or whatever oh here is a scratch-off but
under than that no nobody played it I
always want to know - I think that's a
garbage thing because like you know it's
like the hope that you're gonna win like
five million dollars or whatever I don't
think like really rich people are doing
that on Christmas no that's why I asked
if she had any lottery winners in your
family because no matter how much money
you get lottery winners are always
[ __ ] garlic yeah it's how the lottery
changed my life or ruin my life or
something and they all do trashy things
with the money it's not like it goes
right into like some like investment
they buy houses for all their other
family members like in the same
cul-de-sac yeah
and then they're broke yeah all go broke
they end up shooting each other like two
million dollars is like 200 million
dollars yeah yeah they spend it like
they're gonna keep making two billion
dollars right man if I won the lottery I
would be [ __ ] I'd be on Sunny D what
do you mean Sunny D a case of Sunny D
and head to Disney World
yeah I'd buy up all the cactuses in the
world and further them out to see that's
right
karlie I can't thank you enough man this
was so much fun
all right normally normally we get out
of the house we're going around the
different things that was so much fun
that would that would that we just it
was all childhood it was all in the
house I [ __ ] loved it man that was so
much anything anything do you want to
tell the folks about I know you got the
secret keepers podcast anything coming
up I know we're a little bit of a
standstill right now
[Laughter]
at first I'm like oh it's gonna be a
couple weeks and then I'm like no
novelty is wearing off they're not the
same thing
the only wearing off yeah yeah another
another month I'd be happy for if it was
over if we're like tips like summer yeah
that's gonna [ __ ] sock yeah it's
gonna get to the point where people are
just gonna start [ __ ] going out again
in the first place it should have just
been like everybody in the whole country
had has to stay inside but started it
off yeah I mean people in Florida are
still going out you know what I'm saying
until like a few days ago they finally
put them on lockdown so it's just like
it's it's gonna get worse before it gets
better but it'll be fine we were
laughing the other day about the
governor of Georgia is that who it was
it was the mayor of Atlanta do you see
this Carly I think it was the governor
of Georgia like literally like two days
ago was like I didn't know that you came
you could pass it if you weren't showing
symptoms I'm like [ __ ] I knew
that too two weeks ago I knew that yeah
we knew that
a month ago he's like not sorry
yeah that's garbage just play dumb for
the cameras Jesus Christ even if he
didn't know that why would you say it
it's crazy it's legit crazy man Scott
it's not so much fun Kippy anything uh
we got to tell him yeah guys thank you
so much for listening please rate review
subscribe on iTunes you can follow us on
Spotify wherever you listen to podcast
also the videos will be up on YouTube
the same day it comes out on audio so
please you know subscribe comment give
us a thumbs up there we appreciate all
the support yeah absolutely appreciate
guys very much thank you so much for
listen and make sure you check us out on
YouTube watch the podcast you got
nothing else to do check it out Carly
Aquilino buddy thank you so much for
coming and talking to us it was so much
fun we'll see you guys soon okay all
right guess what I keep wanting to tell
you you know what's awkward about this
is the the second before you hit the
leave because FaceTime things you always
say goodbye and they go kay bye and then
it takes you a second to like fumbles to
the leaf thing and I always feel like
I'm looking an idiot like you always
make like that weird awkward eye contact
right before yeah yeah everybody leans
in all right all right let's all do it
together you ready well hold on I just
want to let you know we'll still I have
to hit stop there's gonna be another
second where we're still in here but
alright alright go hi everyone on three
one two three